RANGERS WINNING LAST NIGHT
AGAINST THE PENGUINS.
REAVES TOWARDS THE NET.
HE SCORES!
SHORT SIDE AND THE RANGERS WITH
A 1-0 LEAD.
>> Keith: GOOD, STRONEW YORK RA
RANGERS.
NOW  PANARIN.
>> Eddie: GOOD DEFENSIVE PLAY
THERE.
ZIBANEJAD.
SEIDER, CROSS-ICE PASS.
>> Keith: SHOOTING MENTALILI
JONESY.
>> Kenny: NEMETH, SCORE!FF PLAY
TOO, JONESY.
THE DEFENSE PUCKS.R AND THEN
BERTUZZI WALKS HIGH IN THE SLOT
AREA AND H.
>> Kenny: ZIBANEJAD.
VATRANO KEEPS IT PANARIN AND BL
IT TO THE FAR SIDE.
EXCELLENT JOB ON THE FORECHECK
TOO MUCH.
>> Eddie: YOU BETTER CHECK YOUR
GREE THE QUICK PAD OF THE
LINESMAN AND THEN THE SHOT BY
STAAL OFF THF
THE ZONER LINDGREN. THE PUCK.
>> Eddie: SEE HOW AGGRESSIVESKA.
>> Eddie: AND MAYBE THE STICK OF
BY THE RIGHT PAD OHAVE SWITCHED.
HERE'S BERTUZZI, BLOCKED BY
BACK IN HIS HOME STATE.
IT